this is like a like science experiment
hooking us so complicated there's no way
a child can do this hi I'm Jackie my
name is Tony I'm Jasmine and today I'm
gonna be trying to make some Japanese
candy it looks so cute
oh no the instructions are in Japanese
I'm realizing right now and I don't
think I have the patience to make food
just in general I don't cook for myself
so making food out of candy very
detailed and finely crafted and small
it's very scary our snacks are not this
cute oh I really wish the instructions
were in English there's a picture of
it's a picture of a plate and utensils
I'm also just like a messy figure out a
way to do things yourself like don't
follow directions type of person rocky
egg a panda rice ball meatballs and
squid this is this is my worst nightmare
I go to hell and Satan just makes me do
this okay this is sweet so here's the
confusing right now do I fill every
single ingredient do I fill the water to
just the rim for every little
compartment what what is that though
that you just add water and it gets to
this this squid portion is next its
jiggly my ice cream is not solid really
it's mostly wet thankfully I didn't
throw away this box whoa this it's
really like forming and
I don't know if I'm excited to eat this
it feels unsafe
I can imagine adults enjoying this
activity for their children they bought
them candy tell the kids to make it
themselves they're preoccupied for three
or four hours this is like a like
science experiment looking it's so
complicated there's no way a child can
do this this is an embryo you know how
things are like people love things when
they're small like that's never been my
life I just look like a giant preparing
something for Thumbelina all right here
we go
oh it's actually not too bad oh it's not
like super watery I actually think that
looks pretty good
I need to marry someone that likes to do
this with kids this is what it's
supposed to look like this is what I've
ended up with oh my god I actually think
this actually doesn't look too bad it
doesn't look anything like it but it's
not horrible I think I did it
I really think I did it I'm do I have to
eat them
[Music]
even though this looks disappointing as
hell and she's so so sweet
okay it's not the worst thing ever nope
okay I was able to create something okay
and you know what I think I did a pretty
good job
it didn't look exactly like this but I
think very few people on this earth can
pull off this photoshopped nonsense I
might do this again why not I would
never do this again
[Music]